and come sail away it was in fact an
alien abduction did you know that Eugene
I did not know that yes it was Eugene
Mirman the enemy is a comedian from
Brooklyn Brooklyn in the house yes so
welcome to Startalk radio welcome back
everyone
Eugene Mirman before the great said that
the way the aliens can infiltrate us is
if they paint u.s. air force on their
spaceships and then we'll just say that
they were and then they'll be like
obviously it's a US Air Force spaceship
it's a new and I'm worried since this is
a broadcast show yeah that signal was
not going out at the speed of light and
you've given away our last a loaf of
defense against these invasion yes it
was the last piece we'll put on wigs and
dress like human this that's all they
were missing some other things that can
be me sick of weather balloons you know
weather balloons are not commonly
launched near urban areas or near
airports because they would tangle up
your airplane so the only in very
secluded areas and occasionally
unexpected air gusts can carry into
populated areas and no one has any
experience looking at a weather balloon
why was it does it look insane well no
it's just not something you've ever seen
unless you were like a weather balloon
person right you live where they do this
sort of thing all the time you have the
money to Google the word weather and so
Lou Roswell is in Roswell you know the
entire economy down there is alien based
if you've ever visited the town I've
been there a couple of times actually
went to all the museums it's an entire
alien economy the street lamps have
alien faces on them and things and so
that was Lee reported as that crash was
later reported as a weather balloon and
when combined with some other
experiments that had been done with sort
of dummies people now sort of remember
that is sort of aliens photos of the
actual weather balloon on fragments of
it yes oh yeah well though the payload
that was part of the weather balloon
weather balloon exploded is that I don't
know I don't know what was the
consequence of that I can tell you this
that if an alien really did come that
far and it crashed you're on earth
that's not the only I want to meet
that's like anyone who can navigate
better right I don't want to be the
alien that came here
do you think that there are also liberal
aliens who would try to stop the media
meaner aliens from taking over